chants similar to the once chanted on
the streets of Sudan during
anti-government protests which started
last December that's how people
commemorated the anniversary of the
country's first revolution in 1964 and
even though the most recent revolution
overthrew the country's longtime
President Omar al-bashir in April
protestors say his regime isn't really
gone we want them completely gone
they're still in power still hold
position we're not for revenge they can
work like any other Sudanese but they
can't be in the government holding
positions of power after we sacrifice
lives to bring change to the country
[Music]
Monday's demonstrations were called by
neighborhood resistance committees
bodies that mobilize protesters over the
past ten months they targeted their
allies in the forces of freedom and
change that's the coalition that
represented these same protesters in
talks with the military council that
Elstad and Bashir a transitional
government was formed in August but
protesters say it has not done enough to
dismantle the old regimes institutions
or meet their other demands we are here
to tell the world that our revolution is
not over we demand justice for our
martyrs who were killed in the protis
for all those killed by the old regime
we want justice for the girls who were
raped for those whose lives were
destroyed 10 months after Sudan's
revolution began people here are still
demanding justice
Prime Minister Abdullah Hamburg has
appointed a fact-finding committee to
look into the killings of protesters in
early June but many years a crimes
committed by the former government of
armadale Bashir must also be
investigated ham Duke was sworn in as
Prime Minister in August he says the
government is still new and that reforms
need to be a joint effort between it and
the government not shaded veteran
Sharon's for mafia since the civilian
government formed a month and a half ago
some steps have been taken to cement
civilian rule and achieve the goals of
your revolution what we need to do
together is change that into complete
accomplishment and that can be done by
working together to reap
what we'd sown with sweat tears and
blood your government the revolutions
government research that changes an
ongoing process and needs a huge effort
to be completed protesters who came out
on Monday say they'll give the support
they can to the transitional government
which will continue to remind them what
they came out for when they started the
latest revolution and won't stop until
that is achieved Heba morgen al Jazeera
cartoon